hello this is Matthew from simply
learned and today we're gonna delve into
git and what it actually is and how it
fits within your DevOps stack so a
little scenario before using Gibbs one
of the challenges that a lot of
developers and development teams would
have had his developers would be working
on different types of code where those
database code whether it was Python or
whether it was Java or.net and they
would have a central server that they
would be pushing all of their source
code in but there was little or no
communication that was actually going on
in between all the developers you know
the challenge you had with that scenario
is that when people would be checking a
code you could be like you know there'll
be conflicts and you'd have to roll back
different code versions and and this is
really kind of the challenge that get
addresses git is a tool that allows all
other developers no matter what stack
they're working in to have access to all
of the code and it makes it much more
effective of being able to have
development teams work on small medium
or even massive applications and some of
the biggest applications out there are
managed through a get distributed server
environment so let's jump into what
we'll be covering so you have a clear
understanding of the value that you're
gonna get out of watching this
presentation so I'm going to go through
DevOps and the tools available for
DevOps we'll talk about what version
control means within a DevOps
environment and cover the two different
types of version control centralized and
distributed and then we're going to zero
in on git which is a really fantastic
distributed version control system and
we'll go through understand that the
features workflow branches of commands
in git we can give you a demo and then
summarize all the activities at the end
of the the presentation so what is
DevOps well this is one of my favorite
questions I love their idea of what
DevOps is so DevOps really is a culture
of being able to deliver solutions
faster where your development teams and
your operation teams work effectively
together the idea is to be able to
continuously build out solutions and
have testing codes that's built into
your solutions so that no matter where
they are in the stage of the integration
and deploy
life cycle they're always being tested
and you can always have code being ready
to be released out the idea is that
instead of having big releases that
you'd have maybe once every two weeks or
once a month that you would actually
have a continuous stream of releases
because you always have code that is
being tested you have your network
that's being tested you have your
environment being tested and you'll be
able to provide feedback directly to the
appropriate person whether they're in
debts or weather and Arps to be able to
be successful at being able to deliver
solutions faster the bottom line your
dev team things like operations and your
operations team begin to fill that and
think like developers it's really a
fantastic way of being able to speed up
delivery and have your team just think
and feel and act in a different cultural
environment so let's have a look at some
of the tools that are available to you
in DevOps environments if we look at
DevOps it's really kind of split into
two areas the dev side you have building
code planning and testing and then on
your ops side you have release to plant
operating your monitoring but the tools
really all interact with each other and
what's really great is that the tools
are either open source or very very low
in cost in fact most of the tools you're
seeing in front of you right now our
open source tools which means there's no
licensing to you and you can actually
effectively manage them and implement
them within your team right now so let's
have a look at some of the dev tools
that you have for doing code versioning
and so some of the tools that you may
have used in the past include subversion
team foundation serves and get these are
all different types of version control
software you have out there one of the
oldest ones is subversion it's a
centralized version control system it's
one of the tools I used years ago it
really is good at doing what it's
supposed to do which is just a very
simple version control solution it's
open source so it's free there's no
licensing there are challenges with
working with it because it is a
centralized tool rather than distributed
tome we'll get into that in a little bit
but for a very basic version control
system you know it does what you wanted
to do Team Foundation service solution
is something that many of you in
Microsoft world may be using for
long time and the thing that's great
about TFS is it's built right into the
Microsoft environment it's the server
side the services side of building out
your solutions with Microsoft I'm just
recently in the last couple of weeks at
the beginning of September 2018
Microsoft actually just rebranded TFS as
azure dev ops and so you have Azure
pipelines and there are five now Asha
tools as you replace TFS but these are
all tools that are very similar in
concept the old TFS tools are very
similar to the centralized SVN tools
whereas the new tools that are part of
Asia are actually much more aligned with
git so what you're seeing is Microsoft
moving from the centralized server to a
distributed server with their new agile
dev ops tools which is fantastic news
for every developer listening to this
and then we have get and get is a
distributed version control system it is
again open source which means that you
can start using it right now without
fear of having to have any costs or any
penalties and the thing that's really
good about it is that it's really you
can use it for almost any kind of
digital project and what it's good at is
being able to create that historical
record and versioning of your source
code whether you're doing a web
application a mobile application or
you're actually building a Python script
for a machine learning solution so let's
dig into what version control systems
are and how they can be of value to you
so the role of version control system is
to allow developers to be able to check
in their files into a repository and
here you get you here see how we can
achieve three files into a repository
and that repository then becomes a
snapshot or a historical record all of
the files that we're working on and you
want to be able to have it so that the
repository is flexible enough so that as
you want to be able to scale and add in
new files or new versions of a file that
you can actually do that easily within
your VCS environment and the goal is to
be able to constantly have each of these
versions available so that anybody wants
to be able to check out the file can
actually have the latest version or see
a history of how that file became what
it is today
centralized version control systems and
then we'll compare it against
distributed version control systems so a
centralized version control system has a
central server where all the files are
stored and everybody has to check in and
check out from that centralized server
and all of the versions are managed
within that server environment the
problem is is that if that central
server crashes which doesn't happen but
very often but it can happen you end up
losing all of your files and I was
actually on a project where that
actually happened to us and we lost six
months of history of how the application
was created fortunately for us we
actually had a backup but he didn't have
all the historical data so we were able
to at least continue working but we just
lost a lot of files and it took a while
to get back into place so let's now look
at and compare this to a distributed
version control system with a
distributed version control system you
still have a centralized server that
manages the files but the difference is
is that as a developer you check out all
of the files for a project so you can
actually manage the whole project
locally on your development scene and
make your changes and then you can just
check in and out the changes that you've
made to the centralized server the
opportunity you have here is that the
server itself if it goes down you're not
going to be in a situation where you
lose all the history because everybody
that's working on the actual application
has all of the versions of the code
locally on their machine now one of the
more popular distributed version control
systems that out there is git I mean it
really is probably the most popular by a
margin compared to system out there so
you know this dig into you know what
actually is git so git is a version
control system for managing files and as
a developer you have a git client on
your machine and you're able to make
changes and create local repositories of
a program on your computer and then you
can sync up with a remote service such
as github or get lab or the new as
labs environment where you can actually
store files remotely and then allow
remote teams to have access to those
changes in the actual application you
made so you can track your changes
easily you have it's the the tool is
inherently distributed so it makes it
very easy to manage the code for large
teams and you can bring people in very
quickly and you can have people come in
as specialists and spin them up quickly
and have them work on a piece of the
code and then drop them out of the
projects if you want to have a check on
how this works go and start contributing
to any of the many thousands of
open-source projects I get hub where you
can go in with your get tools and just
contribute to those projects and then
finally one of the things that I really
like with git is that it's not a linear
development approach it's not starting
from a and going to Z it's a nonlinear
approach which allows you to have
branches that people are working on in
parallel to your master branch where
people are actually doing the delivery
of the production code so let's step
through some of these features so get as
you can imagine the first thing it does
is track history that's probably the
most important part of having a version
control system it's a free open source
so you can actually go and use it right
now there are no costs of actually using
it it is a nonlinear environment that
allows people to be able to build out
new features in parallel to the master
branch so that you can be constantly
having the master code out there without
and adding in new features without
breaking the code and you can
automatically create backups by because
each developer has a version of the code
remotely it's incredibly scalable some
of the biggest projects out there now
are being managed through git and
because of this scale the collaboration
becomes a byproduct of teams working
together and branching just is so much
easier with engage so as you can see
this whole thing leads to a very
effective distributed environment so
let's step through some of the the
workflow that we have available for git
so the way that get works is that you as
an operator as a developer you have the
gate client on your local
develop machine whether it's a Linux
machine and Mac or a PC and you connect
to a remote server and you pull down the
latest working copy and then you're able
to make all of your changes locally and
you can modify that the codes you can
review changes and you could commit
those code to your git repository that
you have locally and then you can push
those changes back up to the remote
server and as soon as you push them into
the remote server those changes then
become available to everybody else
working on the project so they can be
constantly keeping everybody updated on
all the work that is happening so you
know typically the way that it would
work is you know you would start off
with having the working filed working
directory that you have locally you
would stage those files into a staging
area and then you get those files ready
to be committed to your git repository
and these are all actions that you would
do locally and then connect to a remote
server and then later when you go back
in to work on your project the first
thing you should always do is check out
that code so you always have the latest
version of the code and everybody's kept
in sync so let's talk about branching
and gids so the way that branches work
is that if you imagine you're working on
a project and projects always have a
tendency of getting bigger than you
imagine and what you want to be able to
do is keep that main product working and
keeping it working effectively but if
you want to be able to add a feature to
that product you may have two or three
different groups that are working on
multiple features simultaneously and
what you want to be able to do is give
them the freedom to work on those
individual features and the way you do
it in get is that you can create
branches off the master and while you're
off the the main branch which is called
the master and so each person can be
working on their own separate branch and
then when they want to they can then
later merge those branches back into the
main master and all this time the main
master still works and still able to
produce the right code for the customer
but at the same time it allows the
developers the freedom to be able to
write in their new features and so we
can look at this and a little bit more
visually with the master branch and we
can put in small features of
large features that we can then merge
them back as we need to so this kind of
covers some of the commands that we have
in git so the first command you'd want
to use is called get in it and that's
allow you to go into a folder on your
local PC and or your local Mac and
convert that file that folder into a
local git repository and that creates
that repository then you want to be able
to make changes to that repository and
the commands you'd be using in this
instance would be and commit or status
and you want to be able to sync your
repositories with the remote server so
be able to put the code that you have on
your computer on the remote server you
just push you know get the code from the
remote so that you'd use pull and then
had origin and then if you want to do
parallel development from the master
branch the main branch you would use
branch merge or rebase as ways to be
able to do parallel development and now
we're going to go through and do a demo
on git so we're gonna do a demo on get
so you feel comfortable running the
commands in the interface and you're
able to get get running correctly in
your environment so the first thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna setup
which version of gate that you have and
then we're gonna see if we can establish
some global configurations within your
git environment and we're gonna do sandy
- as the name email address is sandy
simply line and then we're going to do a
list of the different configuration
settings we have so to check the version
of get that we have we do I get - -
version in our terminal or command line
window you can also use PowerShell
they'll actually get you running in the
same environment as well all of these
tours are going to be command-line tools
and then the next thing we're going to
do is we're going to assign some global
user names and a global email address so
that we can actually access the get
account itself locally on the device and
so we're gonna - and we're gonna put in
config - - global user dot named Sandy
and then I get config - global user dot
email and Sandeep dot d at simply learn
dotnet and now we're going to check the
list of user names and email ids in our
configuration environment with - list
and you'll see that we have everything
in there
correctly here is our username right
here and our name and our email ID so if
you need any help when you're actually
doing it if you're working get all you
have to do is to get help config or get
config - - help and this will allow you
to actually get access to the help
screens so let's just go and type that
in get help
config return and this takes us to the
help page that's running locally on your
device and here we have a breakdown of
all the different commands and what
those commands actually do within a get
configuration and we can go ahead and we
could do a git config - - shell and that
will actually take us to the same page
so two ways of doing the same thing so
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to create a test repository on our local
system and we're going to do that with
make directory called test and then
we're gonna move our cursor within
command window terminal window to the
test folder and then we're gonna
initialize that folder to become a git
repository so let's go ahead and do that
so we're gonna make a new directory and
we gonna call it test and we're gonna
move the cursor so it's actually in the
test folder we do CD change directory to
test and you see now we're actually in
the test folder and now we have to do is
initialize this folder as it get
repository and so we're gonna do this as
get in it and it's now a new get
instance that we can actually now use
for managing our git environment so
we're gonna create a new file and we
gonna call it
info txt and we're gonna put some
content in it and we're actually gonna
put it in the folder that we've just
created so you can actually see what
it's like to test out the get
environment with a file that hasn't been
checked into it yet so let's go ahead
and do that so we open up our photo
directory and here you can see we have
the test folder we're just gonna go
ahead and create a default test file so
right-click text new document info txt
open there and we'll just you put really
whatever you want in here we're just
gonna put in this information right now
name equals Sam registration number one
two four seven nine and save that file
close it down now if we actually go
ahead and run a git status command
you'll see that the info dot txt file is
in red that's because that far has not
actually been checked in
to the project it's a new father we've
added it hasn't been committed yet into
the git repository so let's go ahead and
see what it takes to achieve at the file
to the git repository that we just
created so we're going to do that by
doing get add info txt and then we can
commit that into the history of that git
repository so we can do so it now has
version control and we can start doing
forking and other kind of similar
activities when we connect later to our
github get environment so we do git add
info txt and remember we're actually
still in the test folder so it's going
to look for that file in that folder and
just add it in and now if we go ahead
and do get status we'll actually be able
to see that the info dot txt file is in
an active car first what we have to
commit it so we go get commit dash cam
and then we're gonna commit and we add
in some quick text taken right over you
want communing the text file is now
actually committed into the git
repository and it's all running locally
on your PC so we're gonna go make some
changes to the file and we're gonna save
it and we want to be able to see how we
can use git to compare the differences
between the two files so let's go over
and we're gonna make some changes to the
info txt file
here we are his info dot txt we're just
gonna add in a new line go ahead into
the line address and we'll save that
file and now when we go to get we're
going to be able to review the
difference so we're gonna do get diff
and here you actually see that we've
added in a new address file and so now
you can actually see this is the
difference and the difference between
the two documents as you can imagine
when you have code this could become
more elaborate we're at you or show you
code that's been pulled out if you've
run reduced any of eliminating Unicode
or if you added in new code really
useful so we're gonna go ahead and add
our get user name to a remote location
so we can actually start testing out the
file that we've created into a remote
repository in this case we're gonna use
github and you'll be able to see how we
can actually then save that file into a
git repository that somebody else could
then access and be able to make edits to
so let's just go ahead and make those
changes
so get confer
- global user dot username and we do
simply learn and that will associate it
with this get repository that we just
created locally so simply on - github so
simply learn github is the username that
we use on github so we're gonna go over
to github here we are in github and then
correct new repository and then as you
can see with simp there in simply
learned - github and we're gonna call
the new porosity test we're gonna make
it public so anybody can access it and
you'll see that it automatically adds a
readme file and we have our test
environment set up correctly so we'll go
ahead and copy the URL link which is
github comm simply learned - github for
slash test get copy that and we'll go
back over to our command line window and
so now we're going to add the username
to the github configuration so what
we're doing is we're connecting the
local repository to the remote
repository so we type git remote add
origin and then we'll paste in the
address and this then allows us to
connect the local repository that we
created in the test folder with the
remote repository and now we're
connected so now that we've connected we
can actually push the file they have in
the local repository on your PC or Mac
to the remote repository in the github
server environment so let's go ahead and
do that so we do get push and push is
the command to push the documents from
the origin which is the local file to
master and must is a remote file hey and
there we are
success so what we have now is the
father we just created in our local git
repository is acting now in through a
remote repository as well so anybody can
access it so let's go have a look at
that so we're going to refresh the
github page and hey there we are
there's info dot txt has been uploaded
and we're ready to go that's great
that's that's what you should be seeing
so refreshing your web page on the
remote github folder and it could be any
gate service we're just having to be
using github because it's free to use
you'll be able to see that the local
file has been installed and is now part
of the git repository in the remote
server so what we can do now is we're
going to create three more files and
we're just going to call them info dot
txt info 2 & info 3 and then we're going
to
out to the remote server and we're going
to merge everything together into a
single environment so let's go ahead and
create those three files and we're just
going to add those into the folder so
let's go ahead create new text document
info 1 and then we're gonna create info
2 and then info 3 and get my typing
right here okay here we go
there we are ok I'm opening info 3 and
I'm just gonna enter some text in here
and what we do is illustrate how we can
do branching and each of these files I'm
gonna save and then close out and now I
can go over and so let's create a new
branch and we're gonna call it this one
first underscore branch then we go get
branch first underscore branch and this
will be a new branch of the code
environment that we're creating and so
hit return and that allows us to create
a new branch and so what we do is we're
going to move to the new branch so we
can do get check out first underscore
branch and that allows us to move into
that branch and you see that info dot
text is already there which is good
that's what we want to see now we need
to do is add in the new documents so
here we have the different steps we've
taken we created a branch we move to the
new branch and now we're going to go
ahead and add the info 3 txt to that
branch so you can actually see
everything coming together and we're
gonna go it add info 3 dot txt so we're
just adding a file like we were
previously with our initially our first
initial git folder and that file has now
been added to the first branch so we're
gonna go ahead and commit the file to
the first branch and then we're going to
merge the documents into the master
branch so we have everything together so
let's go ahead and do those steps we're
gonna do the commit first and then we're
gonna merge everything together alright
so we do git commit dash M and we just
put in we're just gonna say made changes
to first branch and that's just
documentation so that we know what we've
done and there we are we've committed
the file so we had them that file info 3
txt committed and now we're going to go
ahead and merge the files into the main
master and so we can actually have
everything together in as one consider
environment and we do that by typing in
so this lists out what we have in our
master file so we just do LS and that
will shows everything in the folder and
we have info txt info one txt info two
txt and info three txt and now all in
the first branch so let's go ahead and
we're gonna merge ok so actually before
we merge we have to check out the master
branch so we do get check out master so
it gets us into the master branch and
you'll see that we have just one file in
there in photo
txt so we're going to list out the files
in the master branch and so so what
you'll see is info text info 1 text and
info 2 texture there but info info 3
text isn't there because that was
created in a separate Bunch
so let's go ahead and merge the first
branch into the master branch so we do
git merge and we do first underscore
branch and there we are we've merged it
in and excellent that looks good so
let's go ahead and list out the files
that we have in the master branch and we
do LS and then you'll see that we have
four files including the info 3 text
that we had it in a separate branch now
all in the master branch so there we are
we've gone through and we've looked at
the different commands and controls that
you'd have for working with git and as
we have established in this presentation
we talked about version control systems
why they're important but why
distributed version control systems
differ from your traditional version
control systems particularly when you
have global and remote teams we've
covered what git is and the architecture
of git and the various concepts you have
with gifts such as forking and cloning
being able to add collaborators to be
able to work in your projects branching
and being able to pull and push code
from a remote service and then finally
we did a full demo on how to use each of
those commands within a normal
environment running on your local
computer so really hope that you've
enjoyed this presentation that you've
got some new information if you have any
questions or any additional comments
you'd like to make please make those in
the comments below if you liked this
video hit the subscribe button and the
Bell button so you will get notified of
new videos we're producing new videos
all the time and we'd love to hear your
feedback
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here